foreign
David is in Pittsburgh hi David welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi Dr John
what's up good to see you man
hey hey guys so
I have quite the situation right now
um
I am uh 253 000 in debt in student loans
and I have a
uh two car loans that I'm paying off
right now and just trying to figure out
what I need to do are you a doctor
foreign
pharmacist pharmacist okay what do you
make
uh our household income me and my wife
is two hundred thousand okay
and what do you owe on these cars
well my wife's car is she owes 35
000 and my car is 17
000. okay
all right
and um so you make what a hundred and a
quarter she makes 75.
more than that I make about uh 150 and
she makes about 50. okay cool
how much do you own your house
uh I don't have a house we actually
Brett how long have you been out of
school
uh six years okay all right
are you ready
to do what it takes to get out of this
mess
we are we both are actually I should say
um we have our first financial piece uh
class on this Sunday good awesome good
for you okay
because here's the good news you make
good money you have a good shovel
the bad news is you're in a deep hole
if you called me up and said you were in
this hole and you made a hundred
thousand dollars a year it's a lot more
Bleak than if you make 200 a year
follow me
yes sir
and you've got good you're in a good
career field I don't know what does she
do
uh she is a nurse for a orthopedic
surgeon wonderful awesome okay so the
great news is both of you have wonderful
extra job opportunities
um er or whatever uh to pick up some
ridiculous hours for a short period of
time and you probably could get close to
doubling your income but you'd be
working like absolute Maniacs for a
short period of time the good news if
you did that is you could be out of debt
in a year and a half
depending on how Maniac you get
if you just try to do it with 200
it's going to take you four years and
you're gonna have to sell her car
yes sir
are you ready
yeah we're we're in we're we're going
for this so it may mean that she's got
she's got a nursing job for a surgeon
she probably likes the guy or the man or
woman she works for it's a good setup it
may mean that she goes and gets a
contract job and doubles her income
fifty thousand dollars for a nurse is
pretty low and she goes full time and
also does weekend stuff too are you
ready
I'm ready I'm ready to do whatever I
don't know you're shifting on me are you
all ready she's not uh well I should
throw us one thing out there we have a
baby we have a two-year-old and we also
have a baby on the way so do you want
that's that's awesome do you want a then
man you hit the gas do you want a a
six-year-old who is still sitting with
struggling parents or do you want a
four-year-old who has no idea what debt
is that's the choice it's going to hurt
either way I want my heart to be over
quicker well I don't think uh pregnant
mama is going to be working weekends
absolutely we are so that is though dead
but dude you are you're working all the
time you're gonna be a ghost calls today
I'm ready to go good I like it and we
are selling her car yeah you got to sell
her car
yes sir it's ridiculous you know and uh
and you already knew it didn't you
I oh absolutely I know the baby stuff
does she know it
um yeah she is beginning to know it um
she is fairly new to it but she is in
with us Well here here's the thing
there's a direct ratio and you can just
discuss it with her logically this is
not about you using Dave Ramsey's a
weapon on your wife or John deloney or
anything like that that's not what we're
talking about but it's a simple math
equation darling
the deeper we sacrifice the faster we're
out
and the higher the probability is that
we ever get out
so you're good you you raise the
intensity and the raise the passion
level and the belief level that you both
have to the highest possible level and
cut to the deepest possible core and the
cut is spending and the cut is uh you're
not going to be home you're gonna be
working all the time any Pharmacy Gig
you can get anywhere whether it's
Hospital ER on the weekends I don't know
wherever it is you can use this degree
to make the most money in the shortest
period of time because you don't want to
do it for long
but I I am Telling You for two years if
you'll go bananas you can be free
yes and um that's that's worth doing at
your age especially live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else now what I would do is
I don't think you get off the phone and
you march in and say Dave said sell your
car
that's probably bad strategy would you
agree
I absolutely so I think you guys go
ahead and go to the Financial Peace
University class and you start talking
in a good way to have these
conversations is ask a lot of questions
that what could we cut what could we do
that would get us there the fastest
possible way because the faster we get
there the more peace we're going to have
the more time we're going to have with
our family the more money we're going to
have later the faster we get there the
faster we get to freedom because uh you
know a lot of people in your situation
you've already drugged this out six
years half-assed doing it
absolutely and you got to get you just
got to get gang on man and I want to
tell you this I I had I didn't have as
much student loans as you did but me and
my wife had six figures between us and
so when I look at the income ratio the
ratio is very similar
and I had a two-year-old little boy and
I had a lot of guilt about how much
extra work I was taking on and how much
I was going let me just tell you what
years four five six seven eight nine ten
and eleven with no debt with that kid
has been like very very different
very very different
suck it up have a hard 18 months 24
months to get this stuff done get it
done man
the strange thing is John
um and for those of you guys listening
out there you're listening to these
numbers okay 200 000 income 253 000
student loans thirty five on one car 17
on the other car about 300 000 a debt
yeah right and making 200 but the
ability to
uh you know put another uh 100 on there
legitimately and even more later if
needed with her kicking in absolutely
um that's something to consider but the
weird thing is
the stuff because it's an intensity
passion based thing that drives the
sacrifice
that it's not a uh uh a straight line
it's on a curve the effect is on a curve
meaning that if you do 50 of what I'm
talking about in terms of intensity it
does not give you 50 results it gives
you 35 results but if you do eighty
percent of what I'm talking about it's
not going to give you uh it's gonna it's
gonna tip the scales over the other way
and you're gonna you know when you're
just going bonkers you see these people
and everything starts to it's like a
magnetic pull it starts to move towards
the goal everything in their life starts
to form up and move into it but you
don't get that kind of um that kind of
draw power that kind of suction so to
speak on it attraction so to speak on it
without creating this tremendous speed
and effort and intensity and Force if
you come back 50 all of a sudden you're
you're return on that's 25 it's not you
can't you can't do it right in the
middle right in the middle doesn't give
you middle results it gives you horrible
results that's exactly right and that's
how you get nowhere in six years that's
right was with that problem right there
so that's why when you we say gazelle
intense it works and you go bananas and
it pushes through that is the deal